comme la quasi-totalité du Pakistan
Karachi et plongée dans le noir depuis
le ciel c'est les lumières des voitures
éclairent la ville
les commerces dotés d'une génératrice
peut ouvrir la tête
on ne peut pas travailler sans
électricité je dois reporter mon travail
à deux mains en espérant que le
gouvernement rétablisse le courant
c'est la deuxième panne majeure
d'électricité au Pakistan en deux ans un
pays de 220 millions d'habitants
ce matin les courses données dans la
pénombre
parfois nous devons même sortir de la
classe et étudier dans le froid parce
que la lumière naturelle ne suffit pas
pour cette directrice d'école le
problème c'est le manque d'eau dans les
toilettes l'électricité a été coupée
très tôt ce matin et le réservoir est
évident
pour éviter des situations critiques la
majorité des hôpitaux se dotent de
groupe électrogène les coupures de
courant sont fréquentes au Pakistan même
si les installations sont vétustes le
gouvernement se veut rassurant
le système de distribution du pays reste
sur affirme le ministre de l'énergie
mais les pénuries répétitives
d'électricité risque de mettre à mal
toutes l'économie du pays la stratégie
énergétique repose sur l'importation des
énergies fossiles les liens qu'ils ont
voulu établir avec l'Asie centrale pour
l'électricité c'était pour le gaz etc
n'ont pas vraiment abouti à cause du
conflit
qui continue en Afghanistan pendant ces
mêmes décennies et avec les fluctuations
du prix de l'énergie durant la dernière
année cette crise s'ajoute à une
inflation qui culmine à plus de 24%
selon le Bureau de la statistique
pakistanais un casse-tête pour le
nouveau gouvernement nommé au printemps
dernier ni les gourmands civils ni les
militaires n'ont pu
procéder aux réforme pour améliorer la
situation économique
renforcée la compétitivité du pays
le courant est rétabli progressivement
mais les pannes représentent qu'une des
nombreuses contraintes qui affligent les
Pakistanais il demeure impuissant face
aux augmentations du coût de la vie et
face aux canicules et aux inondations
Records qui s'abattent sur eux ces
dernières années ici Yasmine Raya
Radio-Canada Montréal